Ciao Gu, la mia abilità è quella di PARLARE CON DUE VOCI
CONTEMPORANEAMENTE... Eh sì, è un po'
inquietante però la cosa divertente è
che... Brava! A volte lo faccio nell'orecchio
di persone che conosco sussurrando cose
tipo "TRA SETTE GIORNI MORIRAI!" e simili. Vai
in finale, vai in finale!
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è TALENTI NASCOSTI
Questo video è stato creato in
collaborazione con gli amici di TV8 per
il lancio di Italia's Got Talent, il
talent dei veri talenti nascosti che va
in onda ogni venerdì alle 21:15 su TV8. E per un tema che parla di
talento e della grandezza del nostro
popolo non ho potuto che invitare
all'interno degli Studios de Casa Mia,
una persona che riesce a nascondere il
proprio talento come nessun altro. Mio
fratello Gabriele. Bellissima la presentazione
No a parte gli scherzi Ga, come fai?
Ciao. C'è sempre qualcuno che va in bagno
prima che io inizi a girare questi video
e non ce la faccio più l'aria mefitica
irrespirabile... Cioè uno come fa a fare
delle battute all'interno di questa
camera a gas.
Questo format fa scappare... Questo format...
Fa andare di corpo. Talenti nascosti e puzze nascoste questo è... Un inizio terrificante
Buon giorno a tutti, a te... Mike Bongiorno. E al tuo ospite. Ma in studio con me
c'è niente popò di meno che Maurizio
Costanzo... Tevo tire che te fotte interettati a tapere chi è oppite con Uillvot
teleponateci all'otto otto tette tette tette tei uno tette tei
Bonatera... Bobbi Uilliam sei motto, motto
Hai visto quando c'è stato il bacio di Robbie Williams e Maria De Filippi? È uscito un... BOBBI UILLIAM SEI MOTTO
MOTTO
Penso di avere questa dote poiché
ogni volta che la faccio i miei amici
rimangono un po' sbalorditi, il che sta nel
versare un bicchiere d'acqua senza farlo
tipo
Questo è bravo... Ma posso anche svuotarlo nel senso se poi non la vuoi più
Questo lo fa sempre con...Bravissimo. Ma come fai?
Per me è sì! Dipende la prossima volta cosa ci
porti, versi magari la Coca-Cola... Co co co co co co ccocola!
Ogni cosa che tu stai dicendo, in questo momento mi fa venir voglia di fare questo...
La mia capacità particolare è di
riuscire a fare il verso del delfino *verso del delfino*
Complimenti... Porca miseria! Bravissima! *verso del delfino agonizzante* Tipo così lo fa...
Bravissima, chiara, concisa, non ha
salutato, non glien'è fregato un c***o. È entrata a gamba tesa "Hm hm" 'Pa!' Talento via, applauso 'peee' a posto
Ciao Guglielmo e ciao ospite. Niente io fin da quando ero piccola ho un talento
incredibile che mi serve veramente tutti
i giorni della mia vita nella
quotidianità io so abbaiare *verso del cane*
Non è lei... No, c'è il cane. Non è lei... Dai ma ha messo l'audio...
Se sei tu ti meriti un Golden Buzzer con la faccia. Non è che non ci credo eh
Vi ho mai detto che io so fare il verso del
cavallo? No. *verso del cavallo*
Aspetta, so fare il verso del maiale *risata di Enrico*
Il mio talento è quello di leggere
veramente in modo velocissimo, riesco a
leggere un libro di 400, 500 pagine in
due ore... Neanche, forse ci metto anche
meno. Io non riesco a rendermi conto
perché... Io manco! Allora quant'è un libro
di 400 pagine. Prendine uno. Ma cioè tu alla fine, arrivata alla fine, riesce a capire che cosa
hai letto? Io in un'ora riesco a leggere un
fumetto di Dragon Ball
Tu una pagina... Secondo me non lo legge, lei se lo magna il libro. Dai vabbè abbiamo scherzato in quanto lo leggi su
Scusami eh ma te lo godi? Oddio... Te lo godi? Ho visto una cosa terribile... Ma non vuoi sapere se
si gode la storia oppure fa soltanto "Pronti via!" "Hai capito?" "No" Capito?
*sospiri*
Cos'è, cos'è! Dai ragaz... No, no! No, dai!
Io ho sentito questo "Una cosa che so fare fuori dal normale è" *sospiri* Ha fatto "HHHHHHAAAAAAHHHHHH
Cosa vuoi dirci?
Io disegno facendo gli starnuti
Quindi si metterà tutti i colori e poi fa "Etchiù, etchiù"
Io una volta ho starnutito uno spaghetto... Io una volta ho vomitato.
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite. Io ho un occhio con cui non riesco a guardare in su. Quindi quando succede che io
guardo in su, ho un occhio che va su e
uno invece che rimane giù, di cui allego
foto. Senti ti posso far vedere... Quello
dell'occhio. L'occhio?
Sì. Guarda che è pazzesco. Questo è su, questo è normale
e io se faccio così? Guardami, guardami. Fa vedere... Guarda...
Eh... Voglio che tu continui a fare questa cosa perché voglio che sia lo
screensaver delle persone. Gabriele... Aspetta mi sto paralizzando. Quindi tu il 'Mpah' non lo puoi fare... È vero! Tu non puoi fare 'Mpah'
Però lo sai che è un'evoluzione molto figa che può essere perché qui c'è lo sdegno e qui ti
continua a guardare perché l'occhio verso il su è lo sdegno e qui è 'Aaaaaaaah!'. Che continua a giudicarti capito
È bellissimo... È un'evoluzione. Allegaci un
video in cui fai questo 'Mpah'
Io riesco a scrocchiarmi parecchie ossa del mio corpo ma la cosa più strana
che riesco a scrocchiare, riesco a
scrocchiarmi il pisello, sono l'unico? Non
lo so, mi sento tipo strano. Come si fa? Come fai?
Io so che si può rompere... Te lo ingessano? Sì!
Scrivono le firme sopra "Guarisci presto" Io so scrocchiare il naso
Io pure lo so fare. Bravo! Ma lo sai come si fa? Tu lo sai fa? È una finta... Ah... Elia te lo ricordi che disse
"Anch'io lo so scrocchiare" 'Track, track' E se lo scrocchiò per davvero. Noi così
Io so scrivere con la destra e la sinistra
contemporaneamente, partendo da uno
stesso punto, andando in due direzioni diverse e quindi il risultato è che posso scrivere
diciamo allo specchio, determinate parole. Cosa devo scrivere? 'Stupefacente'. Ma hai una scrittura da cane
Oddio. Sembra la Befana. Questo è il mio. Allora tu devi scrivermi ehm 'spilungone'...
Posso dirti che la tua destra
che va dritta giusta per la sua via fa
schifo. Devo scrivere col naso... Con le narici. Scrivi 'albero'. Così proprio mi fai sbagliare sul facile, sembro ancora più un cane
Al-be... Ma che è! No, scusate... Ma guarda il tuo albero al contrario
Parto con la premessa che non ho particolari talenti nascosti se non una
risata molto particolare, paragonabile a
spruzzini, rane, insomma vabbè. Vi allego qua sotto il video e ti faccio complimenti
per tutto quello che fai e per le tante
risate che mi hai fatto fare
Grazie mille allora vediamo un pochino
come ridi tu invece
Cioè l'ha pure montato... È stata brava
È multi uso. È brava, è una visionaria
Eh ciao Gu, io ho un talento, solo uno e me ne vanto parecchio e so fare il verso della
tartaruga quando si accoppia *verso tartaruga di Gabriele* Arriva eh *verso tartaruga* Brava eh. Grazie, ciao Gu
Ma come fai a sapere qual era? Eeeh è un video molto famoso, molto bello, quello delle tartarughe *verso tartaruga*
Ma anche tu lo sai fare Gabriele ma sei dolcissimo *verso tartaruga* Ma sono adorabili... È brava, è
talentuosa. È talentuosissima
Il mio potere, la mia particolarità è quella di saper imitare alla perfezione delle ragazzine
"Papone" Che hanno degli amplessi negli Entai *amplesso Entai*
Che poi è un mix con la tartaruga eh... Cioè c'è comunque un mix della tartaruga in ognuno di
noi
'Il rutto parlato' CiAo Gu, CiaO oSpitEEEE. Questo è il mio talento... Hai visto come mi ha salutato bene a me?
Mi ha incitato mia sorella a
mandarti questa clip audio, la quale è la mia più grande fan, anche la tua tra l'altro
visto che ti segue da quando lei aveva
all'incirca 17 anni e adesso morta
No scherzo... Oh Dio. Adesso ne ha 27
Il talento innato che mi
distingue è che riesco ad azzeccare la
posizione dei capezzoli, al primo colpo,
in particolare sui maschi. Non importa se
la persona indossa un giubbotto, quanto è
alta, quanto è magra, quanto è piccola, io
riesco a indovinare, al primo colpo,
dove si trovano i capezzoli e quindi niente...
Un talento veramente inutile
Lllà... Qui ci sta praticamente il mio ombelico
Così è più facile... Lllà... No. Eh pure io avrei detto là... Ma è l'ascella lì! Vabbè quindi è un potere sì. Noi chiaramente no
Il mio talento nascosto è la capacità di sentire una discussione
di due persone che stanno parlando,
anche abbastanza lontano da me e
malgrado il chiasso, se io guardo due
interlocutori e mi concentro, il chiasso
attorno a me si annulla e sento, solo ed
esclusivamente le loro voci
Cioè tu sei la regina dei c***i degli altri.
Vicino a te nessuno è salvo... Come si dice ehm all'interno di un talent 'Me cojoni'
Quando mi addormento e sento che mi vengono delle fitte al ginocchio, ogni tot, ogni magari tre
tre secondi. Vuol dire che il giorno dopo verrà a
piovere forte. Se è una fitta continua,
ovvero che mi fa male il ginocchio per
tanto tempo, vuol dire che niente sarà solo nuvoloso... Però riesco a prevedere il
cambiamento del tempo in generale. Per via dell'umidità
Io quando ho freddo batto le mani velocissimo e ai miei amici fa ridere
niente quindi ti mando il video della
versione rallenty per vedere il
funzionamento del battito delle mani e
il battito delle mani sè
Ah è tipo pinguino...
Ti prego vieni qua...
Si è... Però lui è più veloce. Bravo! Se tengo abbastanza morbido... Io no, io non ci
riesco. È un quadruplo di... senti il
calore! Senti il calore!!! COME SCALDA!!!
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
di questo video, io vi rinnovo il mio
invito a seguire i miei amichetti di TV8
con questa fantastica edizione di
Italia's Got Talent
ogni venerdì alle 21 e un quarto e
soprattutto vi invito come sempre a
farmi sapere quali sarebbero, non lo so
dei temi che vorreste vedere su questo
canale, sempre legati a Vita Buttata. Se
non volete perdervene nessuno, iscrivetevi e attivate la campanella qua sotto
Ringrazio anche te Gabriele. Grazie a voi. Ah no grazie a te. Grazie a todos el mundo!
Ci vediamo il prossimo giovedì con un'altra puntata. Ciao. Hola! Hola mis amigos
Scalda tutto!